you get up you warm up and get ready for
whatever the day's thing is going to be
because I don't remember knowing from
session to session what I was getting
ready to do but you just had to be ready
to do it when asked and and it was
fascinating because you know I mean I
certainly had been on few projects that
went on that long so you know because it
was a long it was it was least it was it
was a months it you know you know the
process was very long you know you know
you know it would be weeks in between
the next session but I looked forward to
every session because it was like oh god
what am I gonna say next and how am I
going to say it and it was just you know
and I got to sing you know that was the
that was the that was the that was the
that was the great gift you know I mean
you know I mean it's like and besides
like us besides Jeffrey I I also thought
about snidely whiplash
Larry's growing up he was my favorite
villain so I was like yeah I just had a
ball every time I was just gonna mention
that we had Keith in mind for dr. facili
a right from the start I just seemed it
seemed like a perfect fit but we had no
idea that he could sing and it was like
we were kinky sing I don't know I've
never heard him saying and and he came
in and woke Ann he's sing I mean it was
we were blown away
it was my nephew's favorite song we were
in the car and he would tell me to turn
it on and I thought maybe he might be a
little scared but he's sort of intrepid
he was three and he said turn it on
auntie I said okay and he said now you
go don't go don't don't don't
okay and then I hear from the backseat
[Music]
are you ready that's so funny because
the first tape that you gave me Ron of
Keith Davis voice was the song like it
must been an audition tape but you guys
just gave me the song and said this is
the guy we want to go with and with no
lines which is a song and I don't know
if you remember this you just went and
tapped out a song on the piano and it
was like wow yeah that's pretty powerful
that was a fast write that was yeah that
was the test that I kind of started with
yeah yeah that was a moment for me when
I heard that song I was like this is
gonna be the greatest musical ever
because that friends on the other side
is just amazing yeah it's a it's a
masterpiece it was kind of like the
first Disney song that I felt kind of
had some funk to it exactly because of
that boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
I'm like okay yeah this could be
parliament-funkadelic it could be good
be